oh that burned my nose hairs the last
dab yep
the last bite is what it said the last
meal the last supper
cause you gonna die eating this hot one
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we open up season five with taraji
p henson she's a golden globe winner an
oscar nominee and best-selling author
you know his cookie lion on fox's hit
series empire and she stars in proud
mary which is in theaters now taraji
welcome to the show thanks for having me
how are you think
[Music]
how are you with hot food i'm about here
louisiana right there i'm happy with
that i've long waited for somebody to
tap out before dj khaled today might be
the day taraji ready to go i'm gonna tap
out i'm telling you no surprise here
[Music]
and you want to start not getting your
smells hot
that smells like cutting my tongue out
that's our donkey kong that's the end of
it i like playing donkey kong not with
him and then that's like a chill one oh
this is like barbecue sauce
can i get six more of these please
so i start by digging into the taraji p
henson backstory because the road to
success is always a winding one between
being a receptionist at the pentagon a
substitute teacher and a singing
waitress aboard the spirit of washington
what's the pre-famed job that you
remember most fondly probably the spirit
of washington
check this out we had to sing and dance
and all of that
and we got an option to pick up a um
solo to sing guess what mine was what
was yours proud mary
and they're crazy
it all comes full circle oh comes full
circle
[Music]
where's my cocktail i don't want milk
and water throwing a lot at us taraji
this is not i don't know if you can talk
a drink it's just a drink i don't know
if you can tell but we're not this is
not a cigarette [ __ ]
i know that much
okay this is the this is louisiana
louisiana hot sauce
i can do this
i'm not all right taste anywhere
so i know that you've said it in the
past that playing cookie lion drains you
so it's with a heavy heart that i ask to
summon her now what i want to do is show
you some up and coming rappers that are
sort of bubbling in the scene and i'm
curious from cookie lion's perspective
what the first impression might be maybe
the first thing you'd ask if they walked
in looking for meetings
head of a r my guess is that you don't
but who knows let's see
so this first one is little xan
okay can you rap
or do you write your own minds can you
produce a song yeah you know this next
one takashi's six nights yeah i know
this guy
i kind of found him on internet
interesting look but can you rap
can you give me bars more than 16
and do you write
very important can you produce a beat i
would ask all these guys that because to
me that's important little pump you'd go
through the same questions wow lips love
the hair colors yeah i see you on
instagram putting the money to your ear
but we don't call that money over here
last one cardi b oh she signed baby i
signed her right away she signed all
right you ready to move on how cardi b
is
oh honey she goes here
[Music]
oh
god an unknown stratosphere for you you
can smell it and see
oh no this is this this is gonna be okay
we're still gonna chill
spot
[Music]
i dance with chicken i know that you
love to cook especially on thanksgiving
but it's your reputation for making
amazing chili that precedes you to those
of us here at first we feast
is it true that mary j blige loves your
chili so much that she has you freeze
bags whenever you make it if she knows
she's coming to where i am
so say make that chili
and freeze it
and i have nicole come pick it up
is that your assistant
what makes mary jay such a great go-to
sushi partner we have incredible
conversations we laugh and we love sushi
and then we got us a good little wow
shut it down
all right you ready to move on taraji
yes
[Music]
do you don't you hate that person has to
smell their food wait how how how that
in this area what's going on
[Music]
we're only one two three four eight
a little bit already
is that how you do you stick your tongue
in here
it's a new that's new to me i have not
seen that from this side of the table
but it's curious
did it work
a little bit
so i want to stay on the topic of food
because hot ones and because i need to
know where does winning a lasagna
cook-off rank on your list of
professional accomplishments hey at the
top it looks beautiful you know how you
have that layers you have to have the
ricotta cheese you have to have the
layer of the green spinach and then the
new it was beautiful his
pasta sauce and cheese no colors that's
how you don't win cooking exactly what
is in mambo sauce because we did a whole
documentary about it and everyone from
dc seems to have a different opinion
it's probably a lot of sugar
seems like a lot of sugar is really
sweet i don't know what's in it it's
good it is good i get my
mambo sauce from um what is it capitol
hill capital city capital city
i tried to give y'all a plug i i'm
i'm drunk off these wings and this milk
i don't know
[Music]
oh that that sounds listen
[Music]
okay
in my humble opinion yes i think it goes
like this oh i don't know i don't know
it's waking up in the back whoa come on
can you put vodka in this can i get a
polar bear you know what movie taught me
what a polar bear was talk to me my
character drank polar bears and that's a
vodka milk situation
damn who does that the russians i think
i guess all right taraji so we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham we do a deep dive on
our guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so i'll
bust out the laptop i'll show you the
picture and then you just tell me the
bigger story does that sound good i'm
getting sick i have to go to the
bathroom for real we take those i just
come back seriously around here
what did you get
first things first okay monster cookie
meets cookie that was amazing sesame
street was my most favorite show on the
planet because they danced and they sang
and they they were rapping before rap
and they had the most amazing guests and
who didn't love a cookie monster look at
the excitement my mouth is bigger than
cookie monster
i know that you've treaded this before i
knew you were bringing that picture it
fits our segment so perfectly was this
just another day in the life or did you
go extra hard on picture day that's
that's taraji i love it you know people
calling me hollywood in high school i
didn't even know i was ready to act yet
and and people was like look at little
hollywood i guess they were right
those were my glasses i would those were
not shades those were glasses i walked
in the classroom just like that
with all of that attitude
i can't imagine
one more for you
with the obamas is barack an empire fan
yes didn't you anybody was tweeting
about it you know how sometimes you go
places and you meet these political
figures i'm not a politician ah i don't
like the [ __ ] to be quite honest but
when i have to vote i do vote i try to
pick the lesser of two evils didn't work
this time but let's try again anyway um
they knew everything about me they knew
i went to
howard come back
come back
help
us
help us
all right trajan you ready to move on
yeah
did you zoom in that was funny if you
did all day you just brushed my entire
eye thanks i'm sorry i love you though
no you know crown royal nice you know
who has a song about this and i love her
jill scott
did you know
it's too short my finger got numb
because i kept hitting replay replay
replay can you do a remix will you just
let it play for like 10 minutes
until i finish the whole bottle it at
least you know
anyway back to our regularly scheduled
program
[Music]
oh god karma i have good karma is this
going to kill c i guess
[Music]
this smells hot and it made the chicken
grow hair i don't trust it
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's not nice
what do you mean ow
i spit it out and it's still burning
this is not fair which one is that
six this is a six
the sick sauce coming at you coming at
me i don't like staring down the barrel
[Music]
and it lasts to win the next lifetime
well it has a half-life so as bad as you
feel is as bad as you're gonna feel you
know this is not
i know all of these
that smells like death
insanity
oh that burned my nose hairs the last
dab yep
the last bite is what it said the last
meal last supper
because you
i don't play these games
well you already went with karma so
we're already there we're done
hey who's eating this for me where's my
stunt double
i'm gonna keep reacting i'm not doing
that i i and i'm done oh
that's really hard i'm gonna tap out i'm
telling you no surprise here
[Music]
tapping someone in my security dave
he represents me right right right
sometimes on hot ones you have to bring
some muscle
as someone who failed pre-calculus in
college what was your biggest challenge
playing renowned nasa mathematician
catherine coleman and hidden figures
that dark secret hanging over my head
that i suck in math
but i'm a great actress
made you believe i knew those those uh
equations is it not
i know what i was writing mm-hmm you
felt like chinese
but you believed it god has a great
sense of humor because i failed man now
you go through a role it's just all
about man you're really funny
just like that time when you had me
kissing my son brad pitt like really
i wanted to work with him i didn't want
to play his mother all right you ready
to move on more importantly are you
ready are you ready to move on for me
i'm ready
so this is an interesting situation here
it's like yeah just goes first
we have uh taraji's security detail
taking out wings and i'm sitting here
drinking it's really a uh quite the uh
loophole in our system and he's cleaning
those wings he represents me
so during the 78th annual academy awards
you performed it's hard out here for a
pimp alongside three six mafia why was
it awkward it was awkward i'm singing
about pips and [ __ ] in front of
helen murray but you're talking about
things coming full circle it made
history by winning the best song it did
and i didn't see that coming i literally
turned around to the phones and i said
you guys be glad you made it you know
dolly parton deserves this they owe her
one so be happy
and then we get up on that stage and
that when queen latifah said i knew i
knew they won and then dj paul curiously
shouted out george clooney during his
acceptance speech do you have any idea
why i mean you get crazy when you get up
there you have all the people that you
love and look up to all in one room it
kind of makes you
have tourette's all right taraji are you
ready to move on are you ready to move
on i'm ready stop
so this next one is to bomb beyond
insanity that would be this one here
and it's a very steep ramp up for you
taraji you're very lucky to have this
guy in your corner
that's hot
the ball
your mouth is going to blow up
no
you're not even sweating
i'm finded we like this stuff
that's why he's my partner
you have anybody from trinidad on your
team no it's my biggest problem
so i think it's a good time to talk
about the new addition to the henson
family i'm talking about cabal at french
bulldog so adorable on his throne don't
bring him up because i miss him you do
this is the first time i've been away
from him big boy's like one of my
friends i follow him on instagram and he
started posting these beautiful pictures
of these dogs i'm a dog person i can't
help it i was longing for another babe
and so i'm scrolling along and i see the
um big boy and i'm like oh my god i just
fell in love with those little faces
and then he found the perfect one for me
and it was my christmas gift k ball
what's the name in reference to k ball i
don't know when i saw the dog before i
even got him in my hands i said he looks
like a k-ball like a football player
just like
so that's how he got the name
okay this is a dog here's mad dog 357
with number nine plutonium
they have a bullet on this thing
speaking of assassins everything coming
full circle today taraji
do you think i would ever put something
in my mother has a bullet on the side
i want to be as far away from death as
possible i feel you i feel you unless a
fat check is coming in and makeup and
they put in the cask and i get to get up
after right right right and get that
check right right away i'll play with
that i feel you i feel you
hopefully someday for me until then i
guess i'll just scrap it out over here
scrap it out
all right so uh mad dog 357 with number
nine plutonium
you do your own stunts in the primary
all the fights did you have to do
anything do you have to take uh any
self-defense questions did you have to
do anything between save by the bell and
er which girl
baby i should have wanted to shoot a lot
of guns on my own time really with the
hand cannon so entourage
yeah crabs
that could sound really weird and they
wanted to keep me over there but then
they decided to make the recurring role
of their god i'm not giving my recipe
but i will give you a sample one day
when i come back i knew i could do it i
was just nervous because i didn't have
the time to prepare like i'm usually but
that seems to be the going thing for me
i never have time to prepare for a role
anymore
all right taraji
okay david
[Music]
taraji so this is the last dab we call
it the last dab because it's tradition
around here to put a little extra on the
last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
but it looks like it was
ordered can i get some um
milk yeah he needs milk
i'll keep it there you go
who had this ground royal though
on deck i'm locked let me smell it
smells like trinity
the last dab
you kind of want to go that bird my nose
it actually smells good but i wouldn't
mess with you want more
not smell like just smell like trini
purple sauce that's what that smells
like all right here we go my man i love
that stuff
such a such a ride to the top with you
[Music]
all right taraji here you are at the top
of the mountain at least by proxy at
least by extension yes so you're clearly
fearless in the face of danger i
wouldn't expect less from someone who
did most of her own stunts but i'm
scared of hot sauce but it is award
season and i don't see how we can get
away without giving you a hot one's
lifetime achievement which in this case
is a bottle
of capital city mumbo sauce i think
it'll look great on the mantel next to
the golden globe who would you like to
thank for giving you the strength to
battle the wings today i have a feeling
i know who's at the top of the list
me
i'm amazing i amaze myself like no my
security dave is a beast okay and if you
see me on the streets i wouldn't mess
with me you saw this man take the last
dab you saw this man have a 25th
anniversary with a bullet
and the bomb and it goes on and on don't
mess with us
in theaters now go see it keep it alive
tell all your friends tell your church
uh tell the mosque tell
buddha
tell
gandhi summon them back to life and have
everybody come
the dead and the living the living if
you don't come i'll kill you though
joking
all right taraji
i was like what are we doing you got me
eating chicken
i didn't know it's gonna be this fun
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans it's
shawn evans and you know what i'm not
going to beg for your subscription if
you're not subscribed
turn off the video it's over i want just
my subscribers come here come here if
you're subscribed to first we feast i
just want to say thank you and then i
appreciate you that i love you and i
hope that you have a great day